because when you got to LA you got lucky
with headshots very early on yeah that
was yeah that was something that I knew
I needed was headshots everyone says you
needed shots and so I was on the hunt
for headshots but I was completely broke
and I was I was at the post office in
West Hollywood which is a an area in LA
that's like a predominantly gay area and
I was there getting hedge getting
[Applause]
I know I saw this this guy was like was
had this look he was like like he
recognized me I was like hello he was
like you look familiar have I shot you I
was like I've never been shot you shot
me and he was like no I'm do you model
I'm a photographer do you model and I
was like no but I need have you ever
heard of headshots
I need something called headshots I was
20 years old and the guy's like I do
headshots I live like two blocks from
here no I will give you headshots I was
like well what does it cost he's like
just cut it's fine I'll cover you I was
like oh sweet okay let's go I go to this
guy's apartment he lived on the top
floor really nice apartment of amazing
furnishings
he was like listen you probably a little
grimy probably need a shower I was like
that some really good idea tons of good
soaps and probably needed a shower and
then he was like hmm you should you
should probably wear some different
clothes so he gives me like this
nice nice white shirt there's a polo
shirt a nice shirt and and kind of like
helps me and like judges me up and stuff
and we go out on the balcony and and he
takes like a bunch of photos and he's
like directing me and telling me what to
do and he takes all these photos and
takes the film out of the camera and he
puts it in the film thing and he just
gives it to me and he was like there you
go and I just walked out and I was like
yeah that stick to that story
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's silence the audience look at my
hair that was a guy who clearly couldn't
afford a haircut let alone a headshot I
don't know that I ever saw him again I
if you're watching thank you for my head
shots he's probably making money of
those pictures he took of you in the
shower
[Applause]
it's really embarrassing to do in front
of a whole room full of Brits here but
I'll try it anyways so it's like mmm so
I want to say I like a Suisse car number
one we are who's number two
[Applause]